hello everyone welcome to abby's kitchen
at home
um i thought we'd do a little check in
here because i am two and a half weeks
postpartum
and there's been a lot of questions and
comments in my dms
and in the comment section of my videos
that i thought i would quickly address
and we're also going to do a really
quick pantry tour
and a little snack taste test which has
been
highly requested by all of you so if you
want to skip ahead to the pantry tour
and taste test you can do that right
here
okay so let's kick things off with a
relatively easy question
how are you feeling okay so of course
uh that's a pretty common question that
i've been getting and pretty good
i would say um of course i'm tired
i'm not getting amazing sleep um but i
do have a night nurse or night nanny
which
has been really helpful um but my sleep
is like broken because of course i'm
getting up in the middle of night to
feed o um and then of course i'm pumping
a little bit afterwards which i'll maybe
talk about in a bit
um so my sleep is broken so not the best
sleep
but funny enough because i do struggle
with insomnia
i actually feel like i sleep better now
like more
better quality sleeps than i was
sleeping
before i had you know in pregnancy or
when i was trying to get pregnant just
because
my sleep is not riddled with so much
anxiety and i find that that makes
such a difference i wake up feeling
happier and i wake up feeling more
refreshed rather than feeling
frustrated that i've spent all night
kind of trying to get to sleep or
just like doing that work that active
work to try to get to sleep
healing has been going i think pretty
well compared to i think
most mom's um postpartum um i did have a
hemorrhage i don't know if you watched
my
um kind of labor video but i did have a
postpartum hemorrhage so i am still
bleeding a bit i know tmi but that's
what happens after you give birth
i am still bleeding sometimes a lot
sometimes not so much
so i am feeling a little bit weak when
that happens but i am taking iron
supplements which
i think hopefully are helping um but i
didn't tear so
yay i didn't tear in my first pregnancy
either my first delivery
so that has definitely been helpful i
know a lot of my
mom friends who have really bad tears
like it just
the pain all the time and the discomfort
of that
um can just like really throw a wrench
in things
and emotionally i also feel pretty good
i would say
um you know i am prone to anxiety so i
always
worry that i'm gonna have some pretty
bad postpartum anxiety or postpartum
depression
um but i actually find i'm much more
anxious
in pregnancy or trying to get pregnant
and as soon as the baby gets here i just
feel
so much happier so much more relieved
um of just like the worry and everything
feels you know happier and and
everything is falling into place
yeah i guess you could say that
emotionally
i feel like this time around with you
know baby number
two is a little bit easier because i
kind of feel like i know what i'm doing
um but physically it is a little bit
harder because i'm pulled in two
different directions you know
i've got baby e who needs me and baby oh
who needs me i know baby
is kind of bigger now but there is that
kind of
tug of war happening which can be like
physically
quite exhausting um just last week we
did have a brief stint
at sickkids er which was you know pretty
traumatizing i don't know if any of you
read my community post on that but
you know physically exhausting
emotionally exhausting i cried probably
for like 30 hours straight
um just out of you know exhaustion
and hunger and not being able to eat or
pee
or and my back was killing me from
sitting in an uncomfortable chair
holding my baby like this for
you know 17 hours um but i will say that
you know everyone's doing fine now
we came out of that unscathed no issues
no problems we're all healthy and happy
it was a very stressful experience as
you know
as a mom who just gave birth and is
emotionally not 100
there with all the hormones but i will
say that at the end of the day
everything worked out and i'm just so
grateful for
baby oh's health and for the amazing
team at sickkids as well
so by the way um if you haven't seen my
merch line
um i'm gonna leave a link below but a
portion of proceeds are going towards
sick kids foundation as well so
definitely check that out they are
amazing amazing hospital an amazing
amazing cause okay so next question
are you exercising um okay so the
recommendation right now of course
is not to formally go back to your
exercise regime until at least six weeks
till you get the
the go ahead from your health care
provider um i remember like
when i gave birth like that day my
midwife was like make sure that you're
not picking up anything heavier than
your newborn
um but of course that's just like not
realistic
for a second time mom who goes home and
has a 20 pound
toddler who also wants to be picked up
so
yeah like time kind of broke the rules
on that one
pretty quickly um but you know i'm doing
lots of walking i'm not going
to the gym but i'm doing lots of walking
um lots of baby wearing
just kind of stroller walks to try to
like get outside while the weather is
still mild here in canada
and also just to like stretch my legs
and get the baby to sleep
and um all that kind of stuff and you
know hopefully
when when i feel like i have the energy
i will get back to that gym
and i know from my first experience five
pound weights felt like 20 pound weights
they just
instantly felt so heavy but after a few
weeks of just kind of like getting back
into things the muscle memory was there
and i just like kind of felt back to
normal pretty quickly
okay so next question have you lost most
of your baby weight okay so i want to
preface this by saying that
everyone's postpartum body experience is
going to be so different
and just because my body does something
does not mean that you should hope for
or worry about or be scared that your
body
is going to do the same or look the same
also whether or not it takes like
one week or 10 years or never for you to
get back to your pre-pregnancy weight
i acknowledge that that whole experience
can feel really uncomfortable so i don't
want to undermine anybody's
kind of emotions around this process but
i will say that i
am pretty close to my pre-pregnancy
weight just like maybe two and a half
pounds
heavier than i was before i got pregnant
um and
you know i still do look kind of
pregnant because it takes a long time
for your uterus to kind of shrink back
down and especially in a second or third
or fourth or whatever pregnancy it can
take a little bit longer
but i'm honestly in no rush at all it's
not actually something that i
even think about that often to be honest
i
feel like i have different bigger
priorities like feeding my newborn and
feeding and caring for and spending time
with my older son and just like
feeding and trying to take care of
myself and heal
and get semi-rested um but yeah
i'll show you what things are looking
like right now basically
let's get this out of there
so this is my uterus right now
you can still kind of like see where my
belly like it's like
all right that's where it'd be and my
skin is a little bit more stretchy
so yeah i think everything just takes
time right
everything takes time and it's not
something that i'm really even thinking
about
and like i said there is no typical
timeline
for these things every body is going to
be different
every experience is going to be
different some of us may lose weight
some of us may gain weight while
breastfeeding
i for one kind of gain weight while
breastfeeding or at least have a i'm not
going to lose it
um i know in my first pregnancy i kind
of lost the weight pretty quickly and
then i gained back like five to ten
pounds and i
i kept that weight on throughout the
duration of my breastfeeding
journey and then you know when i weaned
it came off
um and actually that's more common than
people think i know everyone says
oh yeah when you breastfeed the weight
will just melt away
not necessarily true so just know that
some of us need that extra weight and
extra fat
as reassurance for the baby and that is
totally okay in my books yeah so let's
all just try to be kind to ourselves and
our body and give our body some grace
and some extra time to just kind of
figure out what it needs to do to help
serve you and baby
best okay next question how is
breastfeeding going
uh good and bad i mean i'm having a bad
day i'm not gonna lie
i was crying before i came on camera and
i was like
should i even do this because i might
just cry
um but i guess it's going better than
last time
you know with with eve we had serious
lip
tongue tie situations happening plus
poor supply
issues so i had like a double whammy
this time
oh had a bad um tongue tie which was
released on day two of his life versus
day 10 with um
e um but o's got r
released um we still have like a lot of
tightness that we're working on
his latch is okay it's certainly better
than ease and he's not as colicky which
is
god sent um but it's just it's not great
like he doesn't want to open his mouth
and that is a problem um supply-wise
i've got enough that's not the issue
which is thank goodness because i worked
so hard in my first postpartum
experience breastfeeding experience
trying to get my supply up and it was
just like
such an overwhelming exhausting struggle
with the pump like
i was tethered to that thing um but i
think that the problem we're having now
i actually just saw my lc this morning
and that's kind of
something we were talking about and i
was left feeling
pretty overwhelmed and upset to be
honest
feeling like i'm feeling again and i
might fail again
but um the issue is that
he he is lazy
he's lazy because he only wants to drink
when there's a letdown
and basically any time that the letdown
stops
he stops he does not want to suck he
doesn't want to work for
that milk and i'm doing like massive
compressions anyone that's you know
breastfed knows what i'm talking about
but
i'm like squeezing my boob like this
trying to force it into him give him
basically like
a faux letdown um to make it easier for
him
so he feels like okay i can do this i
can do this
but then we get stuck in this like bad
cycle where he
conks out he just like falls asleep or
he's just like i'm not
breastfeeding anymore if it's not let
down if it's not easy
i'm not you know i'm not i'm not going
for it i'm not working for it
um and then he's not full so
i am not empty so i have to pump to
empty my breasts
he is not full so he will not settle
until he gets a bottle
and he gets a bottle top up then he
learns hey the bottle is faster and
easier
and way better than having to work at
the breast
and then we get stuck in this vicious
cycle of me always having to
you know do a bit of a breastfeed with
the let down let down ends
he's over it he's hungry i'm full i have
to pump then i have to feed him on the
bottle it is
basically a full-time job and this is
what i was afraid of and this is what
i'm scared of
and i'm just praying that you know
i'm gonna have to work really extra hard
and i'm hoping that with the
the chiropractor and the osteopath work
that we're doing to try to like
improve his latch that he gets a better
go at it
that he's just gonna get stronger and
maybe
less lazy um i don't know tonight i'm
going cold turkey on the
bottle and i don't care if he's
screaming all night we're gonna just
make it work to try to get him to
take the breast so i'm gonna be up all
night
that's probably what's gonna happen and
it's gonna be cluster feeding all night
long
and it's gonna be hard it's gonna be
hard emotionally to have to
listen to the crying all night long but
you know
i feel like we have to get back into a
better rhythm on this
okay so really quick little um update
here folks
it has been three days or three nights
since i spoke to the lc and we decided
and talked about
trying to avoid the top up out of the
bottle at night
and i'm really happy to say that oh has
you know taken the challenge
and has basically been sleeping the
exact same stretches as he did with the
bottle top up
so i've been exclusively breastfeeding
all week long which is so exciting
and i'm really hoping that this
continues off
um going the way it has been so wish me
luck
okay back to the other questions okay
let's bring it back bring back the
energy abby bring back the energy
emotions hormones it's hard okay
how is e loving being a big brother
this is something that's going to make
me smile because he has been such a joy
and it's it's so obviously like his
calling to be a big brother
he's just such an affectionate little
boy by nature so this is like
this is this is totally comes naturally
to him
he wakes up in the morning and he says
his name he calls his name at the top of
his lungs
um at night we have kind of done this
new
bedtime routine where instead of reading
his stories in his in
in his room his bedtime stories we're
now all reading them together
in our bedroom on our bed and while my
husband's reading the story
um and he's right between us i've got o
in my hand
he always is reaching over to like grab
little o's hand
and just like you know pet it give him a
kiss
give him these cute little hugs these
awkward hugs
um it melts my heart and it has made
this whole
journey so worth it um
in terms of jealousy you know one thing
that was one thing i was worried about i
did a lot of reading like how do i
prevent sibling jealousy and rivalry and
stuff like that
um especially at the beginning when you
bring a newborn home but
you know he has shown his jealousy in
the most sweet
affectionate way just because that is
who he is he
um definitely has gotten some serious
mummy itis so
you know that that's not normal for him
i i'm like
not the favorite parent that's for sure
i would say in that first week and week
and a half
after we came home all he did was want
to be
attached to me you know every moment
it's mommy do this mommy has to do this
always want to be held always wanting to
hold my hand always wanting me
to take him to the bathroom or to feed
him or to you know go on walks with him
won't let our nanny do it or won't let
you know my husband or
or in-laws or or whatever he wants mommy
to do it
um and i guess that's just his way of
kind of showing that he's
he he just wants my attention too and so
emotionally and
logistically it's certainly a challenge
but i am i'm gonna take it because i
i love being loved this is why we have
kids right
no it's so sweet it really is okay next
question
would you try again for a girl
i honestly hate this comment or any of
the kind of like comments like oh i was
really rooting for a girl or whatever
like it honestly
makes me want to snap back and be like
oh i'm actually going to try again for a
boy and then another boy and another
voice that i can start my own soccer
team
honestly i'm sure moms
of girls get these comments as well
about you know are you gonna try for a
son or whatever
but i just feel like people need to park
their you know gender bias
at the door do not push don't push that
on me
right i'm so over it i believe
and i believe this even before we knew
that oh was a boy that i
have a calling to raise you know amazing
respectful
caring feminist men in this absolutely
crazy world not to mention i love
seeing the bond the brotherly bond
between my two boys it's just like
so wonderful and you know i do not
believe that there is any perfect
or ideal family orientation but
i can see so many benefits for me
and my family for the unique situation
that i'm in so i actually wrote a whole
blog post
all about this all about reasons i love
being a boy mom
boy mom by the way shout out to my
friend who got me this adorable t-shirt
boy mom
boy mama so cute um but yeah so many
reasons i love being a boy mom and also
just like
people need to shut up why would you
ever say something like that i think
it's a rude comment
and you know for any of you who are
visiting a new mom
or someone who's pregnant just like
refrain from making those gendered
comments
that's just i'm just gonna leave that
one there okay and my last
quick question here are you eating more
now that you're breastfeeding
um i would say my hunger is pretty
intense i
i don't really know how much more i'm
eating because you know i don't
like track my calories or anything track
my food and every day is different
but i would say i'm probably eating like
another one or two snacks and probably
bigger portions
of some of the higher calorie like
filling items in my meals whether that's
like the carbs or the protein or
whatever
plus of course i'm still having like
lots of vegetables and fruit because
it's like
so hydrating and i'm so thirsty so i'm
drinking a lot more water and like
i'm chronically purged right now all i
can think about in my head is like
i need to go get my water right there
that i'm i just need it
right now um i also find like in the
middle of the night when i'm feeding
sometimes my hunger hits and i
it's just i'm ravenous last night was a
really good example
like oh woke up i was trying to feed him
and i almost wanted to just like
yank him off the breast so i could run
down to the kitchen and get some snacks
because i was starving
so i do try to keep like dry cereal and
nuts and granola bars by my bed
um something that i can like easily
shove in my mouth while i've got a baby
on the boob um and on that note
why don't we go take a look at what i
have in my pantry
and then we're gonna come back right
here and do a little
snack taste test let's do it
all right so let's do a quick
little pantry tour all right so up here
of course we've got some protein powder
i've got all my favorite crackers
and just other random crackers that
people have sent me these are actually
my favorite raincoast crisps
so good with a nice creamy brie
uh lots of popcorn because i'm obsessed
and i got a whole bin of different nuts
i have a lot of pistachios because i've
worked with wonderful wonderful
pistachios in the past and i also love
them
um and we've got some like pancake mix
and things i actually got sent this like
kind of protein pancake mix i haven't
tried it it's
birthday cake flavored so if you've
tried that definitely
let me know how it is i am super curious
i
gotta get on it actually and then we've
got all of our like condiments we've got
you know some vinegars and soy sauce
and rice wine vinegar and olive oil and
coconut oil and avocado oil
oh apple cider vinegar i put on
basically
everything and same with balsamic i love
it i'm a big vinegar person
and then a hodgepodge of some spices
we've got some mustard i
love ballpark yellow mustard and so does
baby e or big boy e i guess we love it
on everything
so then we've got some different rices
and grains
of course lots of quinoa i always make
like a big batch of quinoa at the
beginning of the week and i throw it
into stir fries and salads and
you know soups and things like that just
a really versatile
option and i've got a bin here
which i keep all of my snacks so we've
got lots of granola bars in this bin so
i've got lots of bars i've actually
never even tried before because usually
brands just like send me these
but rx bars kind bars are actually one
of my favorites i love the whole
pieces of nuts in there that one's
really great for i think
my my kid loves it too but yeah just
like easy
snacks things that i could throw into
you know my diaper bag or my purse
or gym bag if i ever get to go to the
gym again
and just like have it ready to go as i
walk out the door
and some more snacks because we're the
the house of snacks here
um uh these are like broad beans or like
crunchy broad beans
little like things again like all these
things get sent to me and i usually
don't buy any of them
um but you know it's fun to try things
out and i'm actually going to sample
some for you
i've got turkey pepperoni all sorts of
different options for when you're
craving that kind of like
savory kind of snack and then we've got
some coffee pods for our nespresso
i also have an actual espresso machine
that i use more often but it's good for
guests who come over
and more snacks so these are crispy
chickpeas and i have a bunch of them
again some of them were sent to me some
of them were purchased we've got these
like
little i don't know what those are we're
gonna try those later so i think those
are like pumpkin seeds
we've got our dried fruit so raisins and
dates that i use
all the time yeah lots of good things
for baking and for snacking now this is
one of the fun
shelves i would call it this is my
chocolate bin and
yes there's a lot of chocolate um my
husband loves chocolate my kiddo loves
dark chocolate i'm not a huge chocolate
fan but i do love
chocolate eggs which is kind of fun
we've got lots of green and blacks
different kinds of organic chocolate
these are really great i actually got
those like a sample
so a lot of these again like i haven't
actually purchased myself i just get
sent them
this of course is from last easter it
probably is no good but somehow i've
kept it um i really should probably get
rid of that
does anybody else just like keep things
and forget about them and
obviously eventually they don't taste so
great yeah
gotta do something about that and then
like lots of fun little baking things
sprinkles and
you know little colored sugars for
baking
this is actually um like that pink
dragon fruit the red dragon fruit powder
so it's really good for like making
pancakes pink and things like that
and then i've got another bin full of
different nuts so these are like more
flavored nuts and i've got like some
almonds and walnuts and all sorts of
things
this is a fun this is a really fun this
um basket
bin or whatever this is the candy bin so
we've got some smart sweets
again those are sent to me but i really
like the peach rings ones
um i've got candy necklaces and like
really fun
little things when people come over i
just want to have some fun starbursts
i actually bought those for when i was
giving birth and i ate a lot of them
werthers love werthers oh this is the
fun stuff
fun dip hello 90s kids um
and of course pop rocks so much fun try
putting that on some ice cream it is
a blast and speaking of ice cream
we have a waffle cone i've got also like
cake cones too if you're feeling just
like a lighter cone but we love ice
cream in this house so
we love ice cream cones and also i love
love graham crackers and they're
actually surprisingly low in sugar so
love graham crackers with a little
peanut butter you guys know
i love my ham hearts and i've got more
of them in the fridge so i've got a
whole stockpile of those
and lots of like oatmeal and things like
that for breakfast steal cutouts is a
staple in this house
so then we've got things like coconut
milk and beans and all the tomato
products for cooking tomato sauce and
paste and diced tomatoes and
thanks for making stews lots of pasta of
course
more pasta than i know what to do with
um
uh and this is our favorite pasta i i
use a lot especially for the kiddo
banza it's a chickpea pasta it's got
lots of protein and fiber
so that is really fantastic yeah more
canned goods canned veggies shredded
celery root and carrots and
corn and beans and canned tuna and fish
and salmon and things like that
this is a hodgepodge we've got lots of
tea in there and kind of coffee and
bouillons pickles very important
so important gotta love a spicy pickle
oh and this is the caramelized onion
spread is
really good on grilled cheese or like
burgers or things like that
um got some udon noodles for making stir
fry
really super simple just to like throw
them in um
and lots of other spreads like this is
coffee almond butter
so cool and then of course we've got all
of our boring baking stuff which is a
bit of a mess but you know flour
and cocoa powder and sugar and baking
powder and
salt and all those kinds of different
things
and then a big bin for our large format
snacks like popcorn
and bits and bites another 90s favorite
of mine
and then we've got our basic cereal all
brand cheerios and i am currently
obsessed with this
purely elizabeth granola i've also got
like a drink fridge so
we have tons of kombucha in here i love
kombucha
um this one's watermelon and mint we've
got lots of lacroix
or other kind of sparkling water um
different flavors
i've got some like natural sodas that i
think a brand sent me which is kind of
cool
yeah um what else oh this also just got
sent to me it's a canadian
sparkling water with like natural fruit
juice added to it which is kind of cool
fresh pressed blueberries so yes very
canadian wild blueberries
and of course we've got some adult
bevies in here as well i think this is a
like cider and i think i've got some
like sour beer in there as well
but yeah lots of good stuff all right
and this is the pantry that's in the
kitchen
um all my nut butters for just like
making breakfast super easy
pb2 love to put in smoothies um
some you know honey this is actually a
turmeric honey which is kind of cool
and then we've got like some rice cakes
for you know throwing some cheese and
some
avocado on all my different oatmeal i
eat a lot of oatmeal especially now that
i'm breastfeeding
so yeah just trying to like make
breakfast super super
easy all right folks
let's have a snack because your girl is
hungry um and it is like my snack time
right now actually so
perfect timing baby's asleep snacks are
here
let's get eating all right so
real time thoughts some of these i may
have tried before and i've kind of
forgotten about and some
i've never tried them at all so you're
going to get some honest reviews right
here
and maybe you'll get some inspiration on
some snacks to try
yourself i don't know and also full
disclosure that
i'm not being paid by any of these
brands to talk about them right now
some of them have been sent to me
actually i think probably most of them
have just been sent to me over
a long period of time and they've just
been like hanging out my pantry and
often i forget about them um so yeah
we're gonna try a lot of these different
things and as an influencer
i get sent a lot of different foods and
snacks so
let's get eating
okay so this is called hungry buddha
coconut clusters yum all right so
just looking at the ingredients here
these have organic coconut
there's some sugar in them pumpkin seeds
sunflower seeds chia seeds and sea salt
um and they've got a little bit of
protein four grams and a little bit of
fiber four grams
and about 300 calories per serving i
mean it is pretty high fat so there's 23
grams of fat
it's basically coconut and nuts and
seeds and things like that
so oh so they're like little clusters
let's see if you can see those cuties
yeah
all right well they look good
[Music]
oh my god that is delicious mmm
good for snacking but also i feel like
these would be really good
crushed on top of a salad as like a
crunchy element
i hope i don't eat um chew too much with
my mouth open because i'm gonna be
talking the same time
i really should have brought a drink to
this to this uh
event but anyways that's delish okay
this is huge and i think this is
canadian so some of my american
followers may or may not be able to find
this i don't know
but it says it's proudly made in canada
which
makes me very proud as well and i'm a
big popcorn girl so
we're gonna see how this is this is
called french can can popcorn
and this brand actually sent this to me
and they sent me a bunch of flavors
and i tried the movie popcorn which is
completely vegan as well but it's like
buttery
i ate the whole bag this whole big bag
it is
it was so so so good now this i thought
i'd try on camera because i haven't yet
this is a spicy jalapeno flavor never
tried it before
i thought that was like a little more
unique
so it is trans fat free cholesterol free
vegan gluten free of course
um a cup has just 39 calories a gram of
fiber gram of protein
um but you know i love i love popcorn i
think it's just like
such a great snack it's one of my
favorite bedtime snacks
this is nice like spiced popcorn let's
see
hmm it does have a little kick
could use this one going into labor hmm
that's good not as good as the
not as good as the movie one but i'm i'm
digging this
i could totally eat this before bed i
need a lot of it
all right this is another one
dang dang that's good it says
these are sticky rice chips all right
see
and this is the coconut crunch flavor i
know they've sent me a bunch of flavors
um so this has organic rice
palm fruit oil coconut chips coconut
sugar cane sugar coconut milk watermelon
juice interesting
sesame seeds watermelon juice
never heard of that as an ingredient but
an ounce
which has um 21 chips 140 calories
a little bit of fiber tiny bit of
protein mainly fat
carbohydrates some sugar let's try it
they look kind of like rice cakes but a
little stranger
okay
i don't know what that tastes like
it doesn't have a texture like a race
cake brace cakes are like kind of spongy
these are crispy they're good
crispy aerated yeah
i think those are pretty good those are
pretty tasty
i'd be interested to try some of the
other flavors as well so
this also got sent to me it's called
pit stop whey let's see
these are cappuccino protein snack
biscotti with 18 grams of protein
um what else we got six grams of fiber
130 calories per serving
and i'm not quite sure i'm just serving
this because
this is a better half of this bag i
guess is a serving
all right let's try this there's a lot
of like
maltitol and sweeteners and inulin and
lecithin sunflower lesson lots of
additives and things so
probably not something i would normally
buy but let's try to use cookies
okay so you could like dip this in
in what's it called a coffee i guess
little
little biscotti for your espresso
no nope
not for me that is uh
i don't really like biscotti in general
i don't like dry cookies but that is
because of the protein powder
exceptionally dry i wouldn't eat that
nope nope nope nope
okay moon cheese
some of you guys have probably seen this
before um
i've probably tasted this before i can't
even remember but
yeah or something like it but we're
gonna try it right now
crunchy moon cheese so
um six to seven pieces has 70 calories
um
it's got five grams of protein pretty
good and
very low in carbohydrates so yeah it'd
be great for those
who are trying to cut back on
carbohydrates like this
so let's take a little pixie taste oh
cute
they look kind of like oh they look kind
of like
cheese pellets i guess that's a good way
to
there you go all right
really cheesy intense cheese flavor like
like a cheese curd but crunchy
i could do that i feel like
big boy eve would crush that
love some cheese okay yeah
all right so i have bada bin
badaboom now i have tried bada bing bada
boom before
bada bin bada boom i think these used to
be called
enlightened broad beans i think yeah
that's the brand name
i haven't tried this flavor this is a
sweet sriracha
these this little packet here has 100
calories 7 grams of protein 5 grams of
fiber
it's got 15 grams of carbs a little bit
of fat three grams
um and it's basically broad beans which
is like fava beans
with a little bit of oil rice flour
seasoning
etc
so they basically look like these tiny
little beans that have been dried
let's see and they've got like seasoning
on them they've come
they've got a bunch of different flavors
i usually have the like the sea salt one
mmm this is way better than sea salt
it's like sweet and spicy
yeah yeah that would be a really good
middle of the night snack except for the
fact that
it's so crunchy it would probably wake
my husband up because he hates
crunching noises and then he'd be pissed
but
i'd be happy so that's all that matters
right
let's do something sweet we're going to
go back sweet savory all the things
if that annoys you i want to hear about
it if you can't stand the idea of going
back from sweet to savory sweet savory
let me know i'm super curious okay this
is midday squares
real chocolate this is chocolate peanut
butter
and you guys know i'm obsessed with
chocolate peanut butter so let's try
this
this midday square is
vegetarian um it's basically made with
this is oh real chocolate it says cocoa
butter uh partially de-fatted peanuts
peanut butter
yuck on syrup oat flour maple syrup
cocoa butter date syrup
inulin hazelnut butter stuff like that
um it's got 170 calories per bar and six
grams of protein four grams of fiber
five grams of sugar
and some fat so 12 grams let's try it
now full disclosure i'm not like a crazy
chocolate person
so okay oh so 170 calories for one
square
there's two squares like that in here so
[Applause]
it's a little dense i like the peanut
butter
i like the bottom more than the top the
top is pretty chocolaty for me
like i don't like a lot of dark dark
chocolate
it's okay i probably wouldn't eat it
though it wouldn't be like my first
snack there's so many other snacks here
that i would
gravitate towards first all right on to
the next one
should we go back to savory yeah let's
go savory
shrewd food that's kind of cute
let's see there you go so protein crisp
crisps baked cheddar these have 90
calories in this kind of packet
14 grams of protein um one gram of sugar
two grams of carbs three grams of fat
like it's basically just protein
this is made out of uh milk protein
isolate cheddar cheese
seasoning and like a bunch of you know
other little things so let's try this
oh they're like they're like cheese
puffs cheesies or ch
cheese what are they called we call them
cheesies growing up but i think they're
called
um cheese straws i don't know but
anyways this is what they look like
but like balls see
little key balls cheese flavored balls
they taste like the cheese puffs but
um if they were really really stale
no
no i like real food that doesn't taste
that doesn't taste super real okay
what's next
do this one little tuckers
little tuckers little tuckers cute name
oh little tucker crunchy peanut butter
energy balls
so these 140 calories per piece
which is one ball uh eight grams of fat
four grams of protein three grams of
fiber um it's made with dates peanut
butter tahini cashews coconut almonds
cacao powder
chia hemp flax all the good things maca
yeah so it's like you know all those
fancy pants expensive ingredients that
you find in whole foods
rolled into a ball that's essentially
what it is right now
so you get two of these balls i mean
really
i should just make these myself just
like that
and i do i feel like i really want to
make a
a batch of energy balls with baby e as
like a fun little
activity for us this week i just need to
find
20 minutes of uninterrupted time to
spend with my older son which is really
important
so very dense
good pretty sweet tastes like very much
like dates
like really sweet dates but i think
they're pretty good
i think baby would love this big boy i
guess
i'm gonna save that rest for him
but yeah i think that would make good
breastfeeding fuel in the middle of the
night if i really was starving so
what else vienna
i actually really love these chickpeas
and i love them on um
salads and stuff but i usually just put
the the
sea salt or the plain version i haven't
tried this flavor
sour cream and onion i'm a big fan of
sour cream and onion chips
so i thought why not try the crispy
chickpeas
so a quarter cup 130 calories 5 grams of
protein 5 grams of fiber
18 grams of carbs 4 grams of fat it's
just chickpeas sunflower oil sugar salt
and then your seasoning so this is like
sour cream and
onion flavor yeah let's try this
they're gluten free let's try
so these are like crispy little
chickpeas i often make crispy chickpeas
myself
run away uh oh don't wake up i've only
got a few more snacks to eat left
i like this flavor
i could dig that that's delicious that
would also be really good on a salad
like
like with ranch dressing like um kind of
like a wedge salad
wedge is that blue cheese or ranch i
don't know you tell me folks
i don't know myself sometimes mom brain
okay
now we're in a rush because he's
wrestling rustling these are called
scuda
scooter see
scoota chili maple jango
chili maple jango pumpkin seeds so
in a third of a cup there's 250 calories
18 grams of fat of course really good
healthy fats
monounsaturated fats um
polyunsaturated fats there's some five
grams of fiber 14 grams of protein
wow so yeah these are awesome okay but
let's hope that they taste good because
that's what actually matters
i'm not going to eat something super
healthy if it doesn't taste
really good all right
[Applause]
more
they're kind of delicate look i guess
after eating those
crispy chickpeas which are like hardcore
crispy
these are pretty soft mmm but they're
good
the flavor is very delicate it's not in
your face like
like the like the crispy chickpeas which
are like really seasoned and all the
cheese stuff that i just had was like
really cheesy this is good this would
also be good on a salad i feel like
so i'm gonna definitely save that for my
salads because that's a great salad
topper
toasty tasty crunchy yummy cute okay i
like that
two more we'll do sweet and then we'll
finish with savory because
i'm living on the edge oh my gosh you're
gonna finish with savory
girl that's crazy okay who
i think i've seen some influencers with
this but i've actually never tried it
before so i've keep seeing it in
people's watering days
so i bought it myself this is cashew
butter with raspberry and dark chocolate
so let's try this actually a friend of
mine got this for me
and i've never tried it before but half
of the bar is 180 calories
there's two grams of fiber three grams
of protein i mean
it's chocolate it's not like you know
let's just enjoy some chocolate all
right let's fast into that
and again disclaimer not a huge
chocolate fan so don't like hold me to
this don't be mad at me
it's your favorite dessert of life and
i'm like poo pooing it but i'm gonna
try to give it a fair assessment
i get the raspberry i only get the
cashew butter so much maybe a little bit
it's not bad if you like the combination
of raspberry and chocolate
not sure that i do i'm like
i'm like a peanut butter and milk chalk
girl i don't love dark chocolate
and i don't love raspberry and chocolate
and i don't
don't don't like
orange chocolate that is just nah
stee so you guys can fight me on that if
you want i'm not a fan
it's not gonna happen but i also don't
really like raspberry and chocolate
either so
maybe you guys would like this but not
for me
all right last but not least let's
finish on some popcorn because i love
popcorn i'm probably gonna finish that
i'm gonna eat that bag for lunch really
let's be real
this is another kind of popcorn this is
called pop zero
let's see so this one also has a bunch
of flavors but i thought
we'd try the cinema because i love like
you know i love movie popcorn
um this little bag here has 100 calories
six grams of fat two grams of fiber and
two grams of protein
love popcorn it's the best um
and it's got pea protein in it so that's
interesting and baker's yeast
interesting so the ingredients are just
air pop popcorn algae oil
uh pea protein sea salt and baker's
extract so that's really interesting
huh so this is completely vegan i guess
yeah zero dairy zero saturated fat zero
gluten
no natural food no natural flavors no
gmo corn no soy
no animal products cool let's try it
so that's what our kernels look like
right
that's good good
tastes better like cinema popcorn should
and salty like cinnamon popcorn should
and the kernels are nice and puffy
so that's what i found when i make my
own popcorn it's like half of the bag
gets popped in half
does not and it's so annoying but this
is really good it's nice and
it is salty and there's not that much
though
100 milligrams so no big deal okay
wow well
now i've got this arsenal of snacks i
might as well just keep them up here
bring them to the bedroom and that's
going to be my um every night i'll just
sneak one snack in for for bedtime
eating and pumping and breastfeeding
fuel well folks i guess that is all for
me today um i hope you enjoyed this
really random update slash snack taste
test
slash pantry um tour
i don't know if you like this video
definitely give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below with other kind of
vlogging content that you want to see me
do
um i definitely want to take your
feedback and there's
lots of things that i can do around my
house and i want to make sure that you
guys are getting content that you like
so of course subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen
[Music]
bye
you